mr vice president
i know that this room is full of leaders
of both parties
who love this country and many believe
that for america to succeed
our politics must find common ground
and that has never been clearer
than today when armed rioters stormed
the u.s capitol
emboldened by president trump's false
and inflammatory rhetoric
about the 2020 elections i believe that
we
in this chamber have a special duty as
leaders
to work together to lower the
temperature
of our politics and i hope that my
colleagues who have questioned the
legitimacy of this election
in arizona and all of these other states
now see the dire and dangerous
consequences
of sowing doubt and uncertainty
i also know that as u.s senators we all
take solemnly the oath we swear
to support and defend the constitution
of the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
at this moment in history i can think of
nothing more patriotic
than renewing our faith in the charters
of freedom
that our founding fathers crafted for
our republic
starting with the fundamental american
principle and our declaration of
independence
that governments derive their just
powers
from the consent of the government
the people have spoken in this election
and our only job here today
is to do what they ask it is not to
argue
election security that's not the place
for what we are doing today
our constitution specifically reserves
to the people
the right to meet in their respective
states and vote for the president and
vice president
as a result individual states oversee
and implement the election process
not the federal government to guard
against fraud or irregularities in the
voting process
the states are required to have robust
election security measures
likewise state legislatures have the
opportunity to examine evidence of voter
fraud
before they certified their electoral
college votes
and our courts from district courts to
the united states supreme court
adjudicate legal challenges and election
disputes
all of those things happened after the
2020 election
state houses and courts across the
country took allegations of voter fraud
seriously
and followed the constitutional process
to hear challenges to this year's
elections
no state found evidence of any
widespread voter fraud and neither did
any court asked to review the state's
findings in arizona republican governor
doug ducey
democratic secretary of state katie
hobbs republican attorney general
mark brnovich and state supreme court
chief justice
robert brutnell all certified the
results of the election
on november 30th and we know we have
heard
arizonans have been voting by mail for
almost 30 years
and governor ducey has expressed
confidence in the state's process
numerous times in november he said we do
elections well here in arizona
the system is strong and that's why i
have bragged on it so much
he further stated we have some of the
strongest election laws
in the country laws that prioritize
accountability
and clearly lay out our procedures for
conducting
canvassing and even contesting the
results
and they are right arizona has one of
the most transparent election processes
in the country with built-in
accountability starting
with eternal auditing we have heard
unfounded allegations that voting
machines in arizona and elsewhere
somehow changed vote tallies or somehow
improperly rejected ballots while
claiming to accept them
these allegations all ignore the fact
that arizona counties conducted ballot
audits by hand to double check the
machine counts
and these audits found no widespread
fraud or irregularities
maricopa county the county where the
more than 60 percent
of the state population resides
conducted a post-election
hand count audit in the week after the
election
which showed perfect 100 percent
accuracy
in the machine tabulations so why
would we need my colleagues to call for
a 10-day emergency audit to be conducted
by a legislative commission when it's
already been done by the state of
arizona
what happened to states rights the audit
involved checking ballots for the
presidential election but also ballots
for federal
and state legislative elections the
audit report shows
every precinct's machine and hand count
totals for each of the races audited
and for every single race in every
precinct the difference between the hand
count and the machine count
was zero maricopa's audit report
stated no discrepancies were found by
the hand count audit boards
seeking to find any reason to contest
these results some of the state
republicans then tried to claim that
maricopa county failed to follow state
law
in conducting this audit by selecting
voting center locations to audit instead
of
voting precincts this was wrong
and this too went to a court in
rejecting this claim
state court in arizona found that the
county followed the properly issued
guidance
on hand audit procedures from the
arizona secretary
of state and the court found that
maricopa county officials therefore
could not lawfully have performed the
hand count audit the way the plaintiffs
wanted it done if they had done so they
would have exposed themselves to
criminal punishment
the senator's five minutes is expired
mr vice president i would close by just
saying
please my colleagues do not
disenfranchise
the voters of arizona and certify their
votes
tonight thank you george